So Margy's a reporter, and she wanted to do a story about her dad. So she calls him up, asks him if he'd be willing to do it. They have a quick conversation. He says yes.
玛吉是一名记者，她想写一篇关于她父亲的报道。于是她打电话给他，问他是否愿意接受采访。他们进行了一次简短的交谈，他答应了。
But then he called me back. He called me back a couple of hours later. And he said that he wanted to talk to me about something. And I said, "Well, what?" And he said he wanted me to know that it completely moved him that I wanted to see him with all of his masks off. And I told him, "Well, I don't."
但后来他又给我回了电话。几小时后他打回来，说有些事想跟我谈谈。我问：“什么事？”他说他想让我知道，我希望能看到他摘下面具的样子，这让他深受触动。我告诉他：“哦，我并不想。”
Leave the mask on.
保持戴着面具。
Leave the mask on. It scared me a little bit.
保持戴着面具。这让我有点害怕。
Margy's family is one of those families where everybody tells everything to everybody else all the time anyway. So the thought that her dad would now really let go was kind of daunting. There are just some things you do not want to know even about the people who you're close to. In those moments, when you hit that wall, you get this picture of them and this picture of yourself that is different than you see at any other time. And you have to choose. Do you want that new information or not?
玛吉的家庭属于那种每个人总是会把一切告诉所有人的家庭。所以，想到她父亲现在真的会卸下防备，这让人有点畏惧。有些事情，即使对于亲近的人，你也不想知道。在那些时刻，当你撞上那堵墙，你会对他们产生一种新的认识，对自己也会产生一种不同于以往的看法。你必须做出选择：你想要那些新的信息吗？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters to tackle that theme. Today on our show, Leave the Mask On, stories of those situations when somebody tries to tell you just a little bit more than you really want to know and when you have to decide what are you going to do. Act One, Father's Day, the story of Margy Rochlin, her dad, World War II, and what your kids make of you when you drop one life and start another in your 70s. Act Two, Mama, Can You Hear Me? in which Dan Savage, a man who makes his living writing a nationally syndicated sex advice column admits that there's one group of people he does not want to discuss sex with ever. And sadly for him, it's a group of people who happen to have his home phone number. Act Three, The Unmasking, a story of guys who wear real masks, real masks like superheroes, in their jobs as costumed wrestlers, and how much smaller they feel, how humiliated, when they have to take those masks off. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和公共广播国际联合制作的《美国生活》节目，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目我们都会选定一个主题，邀请各类作家和记者来探讨这个主题。今天节目的话题是“保持戴着面具”，讲述人们试图告诉你一些比你真正想知道的还要多一点的信息，以及你必须决定该怎么办的故事。第一幕，“父亲节”，讲述玛吉·罗克林、她的父亲、第二次世界大战，以及当你到了七十岁放弃一种生活开始另一种生活时，你的孩子会如何看待你。第二幕，“妈妈，你能听到我吗？”，丹·萨维奇，一位靠撰写全国联合发行的性建议专栏为生的人，承认有一群人是他永远不想讨论性话题的。对他来说不幸的是，这群人恰好有他家里的电话号码。第三幕，“摘下面具”，讲述那些在工作中戴着真实面具的人——比如职业摔跤手，他们戴着像超级英雄一样的真面具——当他们被迫摘下面具时，会感到自己是多么渺小，多么羞愧。请继续收听。
Act One, Father's Day. Well, one of the most unusual things that can happen as you age is to see a new side of somebody in your own family, somebody who you feel like you know backwards and forwards, somebody who you have known for decades. Writer Margy Rochlin had this experience recently with her father as he entered this new world that she never imagined that he could ever be part of.
第一幕，“父亲节”。随着年龄增长，最不同寻常的事情之一就是看到家庭成员展现出新的一面——那个你觉得了如指掌、相识几十年的亲人。作家玛吉·罗克林最近与她的父亲就有过这样的经历，他进入了一个她从未想象过他会参与其中的新世界。
About four years ago, my father made an illegal right-hand turn and ended up at traffic school. At the beginning of the eight-hour course, a pretty, blond instructor asked that each class member stand up in front of the group and give his or her name and talk about the law they violated. This is what my father told me that he said.
大约四年前，我父亲在一次非法右转后被送到了交通学校。在八小时课程开始时，一位漂亮的年轻金发女讲师要求每个学员站到台前，报出姓名并讲述自己违反了哪条交规。这是我父亲告诉我他当时所说的话。
Look, my name is Fred Rochlin. I was born and raised near Nogales, Arizona. My parents had immigrated there from Russia. It was a border town--
听着，我叫弗雷德·罗克林。我在亚利桑那州诺加利斯附近出生长大。我的父母是从俄罗斯移民到那里的。那是个边境小镇——
A couple of months before, he had taken a seminar from the famous monologist Spalding Gray called "True Stories: Autobiographical Storytelling." By the time he returned home, he'd accumulated a pocket full of addresses from the 12 or so professional actors that had also attended and a habit of quoting Spalding Gray. Spalding says, "Make 'em laugh, make 'em cry." Spalding says, "Go beyond the frame." Spalding says, "Where's the emotional charge?" Spalding says, "Exaggerate." My father told me that it was very important to "get your work out there."
几个月前，他参加了著名独白者斯伯丁·格雷举办的名为“真实故事：自传式叙事”的研讨会。当他回到家时，他的口袋里塞满了大约十二位也参加了研讨会的专业演员的联系方式，并且养成了引用斯伯丁·格雷语录的习惯。斯伯丁说：“让他们笑，让他们哭。”斯伯丁说：“跳出框架。”斯伯丁说：“情感爆发点在哪里？”斯伯丁说：“夸张。”我父亲告诉我，“把你的作品展示出来”非常重要。
I was flunking out. Well, that December, the Japanese government saw fit to bomb Pearl Harbor. So next month, January, just two weeks before finals, I got very patriotic. And I enlisted in the Army Air Corps. Now, the Army--
我当时快不及格了。那年十二月，日本政府决定轰炸珍珠港。所以下个月，也就是一月份，期末考试前两周，我变得非常爱国。我报名加入了陆军航空队。现在，陆军——
My father kept on like this for about 15 minutes. And then the instructor jumped up, began waving her arms in the air, and shouted at him that if he didn't stop talking and sit down, she was going to lose her job. She was swept back to her place at the back of the classroom by booing traffic violators who couldn't believe that the old guy with the thinning hair, the wrinkled khaki pants, and the white tennis shirt was the one that turned this exercise in forced contrition on its ear.
我父亲就这样说了大约15分钟。然后那名讲师跳了起来，开始挥舞双臂，对他大喊，如果他不停止说话坐下，她就要丢掉饭碗了。由于交通违规者们的嘘声，她被逼退回了教室后方。这些违规者简直无法相信，那个头发稀疏、穿着皱巴巴卡其裤、戴着白色网球衫的老头，竟然把这场强迫悔过的活动搞得天翻地覆。
And it wound up being kind of simple. It seemed like all the kids that were WASPs got sent off to pilot training. And then, kids with German or Scandinavian last names were sent to bombardier school. Mexican kids were given a choice between paratroops or infantry. And then there were the Jewish kids, what to do with them. Well, hell, there were only 10 of us. And every single one of us was sent to navigation school. See, our drill sergeant explained, "Look, everybody knows you Heebs are good with numbers. And all a navigator is is just a [BLEEP] flying accountant."
最后事情变得很简单。似乎所有盎格鲁-撒克逊裔的孩子都被送去接受飞行训练。而姓氏是德国或斯堪的纳维亚语源的孩子则被送到投弹手学校。墨西哥裔的孩子可以在伞兵和步兵之间做选择。然后就是犹太裔的孩子，该拿他们怎么办呢？见鬼，我们只有10个人。结果我们所有人都被送到了导航学校。你看，我们的训练中士解释说：“听着，大家都知道你们这些犹太佬擅长算术。而领航员只不过是会飞的会计罢了。”
About a quarter of an hour passed before my father came to the end of his story and walked back to his metal folding chair. Later, he told me that for a couple of seconds, there was only a stunned silence. Then, slowly, he said the class rose to their feet and gave him his first standing ovation.
大约过了十五分钟，我父亲讲完了他的故事，走回他的金属折叠椅旁。后来他告诉我，那一刻有几秒钟的惊愕沉默。然后，慢慢地，他说全班同学站了起来，给了他第一次起立鼓掌。
It was nine years ago when my father abandoned the square world of architecture to his partners and retired. The first thing he did was rent a small studio near his house, set up a drafting table, and find himself a handful of jobs. It was around this time that he started showing up at my apartment unexpectedly. At least once a week, my doorbell would ring and there he'd be, standing with his tool box. He'd ask me if I had anything that needed fixing. Whenever he'd say this, he'd always have an uncomfortable look, like he was embarrassed. Until that time, I thought I had seen every kind of expression on my father's face. But back in those days, when he'd be standing there, there was something so vulnerable about him, it was almost as if I was looking at a stranger.
九年前，我父亲抛弃了他那沉闷的建筑设计事业，退休了。他做的第一件事是在家附近租了一间小工作室，架起一张绘图桌，找了几份零工。大约就是从那时起，他开始不期而至地出现在我的公寓里。至少每周一次，我的门铃会响，他就站在那里，手里拿着工具箱。他会问我有没有什么东西需要修理。每次说这话时，他总是一副不自在的样子，好像很害羞。在那之前，我以为我已经见过我父亲脸上的每一种表情。但那段日子，当他站在那里时，他显得如此脆弱，几乎就像是在看一个陌生人。
So I'd think of something that was broken, and he'd follow me up the steep flight of gray carpeted stairs to my house. And with each step, he'd shake off a little more of the uncertainty until, by the top of the stairs, he'd resemble my father again. Sometimes I'd wonder if I'd only imagined that he'd seem to be feeling a little bit lost.
于是我会想出一些损坏的东西，他会跟着我走上那段铺着灰色地毯的陡峭楼梯来到我家。每走一步，他似乎就抖落一点不安，直到走到楼梯顶端时，他又变得像我记忆中的父亲了。有时我会怀疑，我是不是只在想象中觉得他看起来有点迷茫。
If you were going to draw a timeline that showed the period before and after my father really got into the swing of retirement, the after part would have to begin with Spalding Gray's monologue workshop, because after that, nothing was quite the same again. Before I get too far ahead of myself, it would probably be appropriate to explain what lured my father to alternative theatre. But the truth is, I haven't a clue.
如果你要画一条时间轴，展示我父亲真正进入退休状态前后的时期，那么“之后”的部分必须从斯伯丁·格雷的独白工作坊开始，因为在那之后，一切都不同了。在话讲得太远之前，也许应该解释一下是什么吸引我父亲去尝试另类戏剧。但事实是，我毫无头绪。
I can say that once I discovered that his dramatic sub-genre of choice was semi-autobiographical anecdotes from the 1940s, I found it a lot easier to get behind him 100%. He is an unpredictable man. As far as I'm concerned, he could have just as easily decided to appear naked onstage, wearing a beret, or reciting the speech of my nightmares, which would go something like this-- "My name is Fred Rochlin. My third and worst-behaved daughter is Margy Rochlin. Rarely was there an argument in our household that she wasn't at the heart of." And if this happened, I'd have to do a preemptive strike, getting my version of things out into the zeitgeist before he did. Let his act be spin control.
我可以肯定地说，一旦我发现他选择的戏剧类型是20世纪40年代的半自传体轶事时，我就更容易百分之百地支持他了。他是一个不可预测的人。在我看来，他完全可能随心所欲地决定赤身裸体上台，戴着贝雷帽，或者背诵我梦魇般的演讲稿，大概是这样的——“我叫弗雷德·罗克林。我第三个也是最不听话的女儿叫玛吉·罗克林。我们家里很少有争吵不是由她引起的。”如果真发生这种事，我必须先发制人，在他之前把我的版本传达到大众的认知中。就让他的表演成为舆论引导吧。
"Writing the One-Person Play," "Go Solo," "The Playwright's Kitchen Ensemble." These are the names of some of the classes that he took, titles that have an uncomplicated sound yet are somehow filled with hope. I can understand why he would thumb through the extension class syllabus and they would beckon to him. For all this, the first time I saw him perform, I was totally surprised what a different world he had become a part of. He was appearing in a group show at a tiny space on a dark side street in Santa Monica. To get in, you walked up this driveway, then into this dusty anteroom, then into this makeshift theater. And against one wall, there were wooden bleachers, splintery gangplanks that my aging relatives who came to support my father teetered along while I held my breath. There wasn't really a stage, just a painted concrete floor with a curtain behind it.
“单人剧创作”、“独角戏”、“剧作家厨房合唱团”。这些是他参加过的一些课程名称，名字听起来很简单，但却充满希望。我能理解为什么他翻看进修课程大纲时会被吸引。尽管如此，第一次看他表演时，我还是大吃一惊，他竟然进入了一个如此不同的世界。他当时是在圣莫尼卡一条昏暗小巷里的一个小空间参加一场群演。要进去，你得走上这条车道，然后走进一个尘土飞扬的前厅，再进入这个简陋的剧场。靠着一面墙，有木制的看台，那些来支持我父亲的老亲戚们走在摇摇欲坠的跳板上，我屏住呼吸看着。其实并没有真正的舞台，只有一块漆过的混凝土底板，后面挂着帘子。
The show began. A couple of hairy men performed in drag so unbelievable that it was impossible to know if they'd just failed miserably at trying to pass themselves off as women, or if their disguises were intentionally for laughs. A skinny woman took a running jump and landed on her knees on a wheeled dolly and came whizzing in front of the audience to begin a rambling narrative about religion which culminated with her holding a giant picture frame in front of herself and doing a wriggling booty dance for the crowd. I can't imagine what my relatives were thinking.
演出开始了。几个毛茸茸的男人表演变装，那样子太不可思议了，根本无法分辨他们是伪装成女人却失败得很惨，还是故意搞笑。一个瘦削的女人跑了几步，膝盖跪在一个带轮的小推车上滑到观众面前，开始讲述关于宗教的冗长故事，最后她举起一个巨大的相框，对着人群跳了一段扭动的臀舞。我无法想象我的亲戚们在想什么。
If you skimmed your finger down the list of names on the program, you'd find my father at the very bottom. It said, "'Old Man in a Baseball Cap' by Fred Rochlin." An hour and a half later, he came out. He looked smaller to me, and he was squinting his eyes tightly. His voice sounded strange, like his, but more emphatic. He talked about being a navigator during World War II, of how he'd witnessed the miracle of childbirth by helping a squadron doctor named Connor deliver the baby of a 15-year-old Italian peasant girl.
如果你顺着节目单上的名字往下看，你会发现我父亲在最底部。上面写着：“《戴棒球帽的老人》，弗雷德·罗克林表演。”一个半小时后，他走了出来。他看起来比我印象中更瘦小，眼睛紧紧地眯着。他的声音听起来很奇怪，像是他，但更有力度。他谈到在二战中担任领航员的经历，谈到他如何协助一名叫康纳的中队医生，见证了一名15岁的意大利农村女孩分娩的奇迹。
So Connor lifted up this gal's dress, but he couldn't get it past her belly, her swollen belly. So he reached into his bag, and he pulled out one of those blunt-nosed surgical scissors and went [RIP], and just ripped that rag right apart. Well, I was shocked. Look, I was very young. And although I'd had those usual teenage sexual forays in the backseat of a Chevy, really, I had never, ever seen a naked woman before.
康纳撩起这个女孩的裙子，但由于她肿胀的肚子，他无法把它翻上去。于是他伸进包里，掏出那种钝头的手术剪刀，嘶啦一声，直接把那块破布撕开了。好吧，我被惊呆了。看，我当时非常年轻。虽然我曾在雪佛兰轿车的后座有过一些青少年性接触，但说真的，我从未见过裸体的女人。
And here was this woman, this 14 or 15-year-old woman, with this huge belly and these two tremendous breasts. And her skin, her skin was black and yellow and blue and purple and red and magenta, all blotchy. And Connor said, "Jesus Christ. I think this gal's got peritonitis. Rockets, we've got to do something. We've got to try to save the baby, may not be able to save the mother. You tell Mrs. Carafa to warm some water. We're going to have to do a Cesarean right here, right now. I'm going to make an incision right about here. And you start cutting her pubic hair." And I looked at that pubic hair. She had hair from her belly button, all over her belly, down her hips, down her thighs, all the way to her knees. It was just a mess of hair.
而这里就是这个女孩，这个14或15岁的女人，有着巨大的肚子和两只巨大的乳房。她的皮肤，她的皮肤是黑色、黄色、蓝色、紫色、红色和品红色的，全是斑点。康纳说：“天哪，我想这姑娘患了腹膜炎。罗克特（罗克林的外号），我们必须做点什么。我们必须尽力保住孩子，可能保不住母亲了。你告诉卡拉法太太去烧点水。我们必须就在这儿，就在现在做剖腹产。我要在这儿开一刀。你开始把她的阴毛剪掉。”我看着那些阴毛。从她的肚脐开始，整个肚子，跨过胯部，沿着大腿，一直长到膝盖。那简直是一团乱麻。
Connor brought my dad there as a translator. He spoke Spanish, not Italian, but nobody seemed to care. The two of them lifted the girl onto a table. And the doctor performed a Cesarean and delivered a healthy baby boy.
康纳带我父亲去那里当翻译。他会说西班牙语，而不是意大利语，但没人介意。他们俩把女孩抬到桌子上。医生做了剖腹产，生下了一个健康的男婴。
Mr. Carafa came over, poured us each a shot of brandy. We said, "Salud," tossed that down. The girl, she was asleep. And Connor packed up his gear, and we started to go. And Mrs. Carafa stopped me. And she said, "[SPEAKING ITALIAN]?" So I told her, "Guillermo." And she said, "[SPEAKING ITALIAN]." And I said, "Connor, they're naming the baby after you." And Connor just sort of smiled and shrugged. And I was proud of him. And I thought, goddamn, good for you, Connor. And good for the American army. We'd done the right thing. And then we started to go. And this time, she stopped me and said, "[SPEAKING ITALIAN]?" And I said, "Frederico." And she said, "[SPEAKING ITALIAN] Guillermo Frederico Carafa."
卡拉法先生走过来，给我们每人倒了一杯白兰地。我们说，“健康（Salud）”，一口干掉。那女孩睡着了。康纳收拾好装备，我们准备离开了。卡拉法太太拦住我，她说：“（意大利语）？”我告诉她：“吉列尔莫。”她说：“（意大利语）。”我说：“康纳，他们以你的名字命名孩子了。”康纳只是笑了笑，耸了耸肩。我为他感到骄傲。我想，该死，做得好，康纳。美国军队做得好。我们做了正确的事。然后我们准备走。这时，她又拦住我，说：“（意大利语）？”我说：“弗雷德里科。”她说：“（意大利语）吉列尔莫·弗雷德里科·卡拉法。”
And after helping bring this baby into the world, my father told what it was like to go on a bombing run seven hours later that culminated with the complete and total destruction of a small town in Hungary that he knew was the wrong target. At the end, the audience did what they did at the traffic school. They rose to their feet and gave him a standing ovation. Then it dawned on me why he was at the very end of the show. No one wanted to follow him.
在帮助这个婴儿来到人世后，我父亲讲述了七小时后执行轰炸任务的情景，那次任务最终导致匈牙利一个小镇的彻底毁灭，而他知道那是一个错误的目标。最后，观众们做了他们在交通学校所做的事情。他们站了起来，给了他起立鼓掌。这时我突然明白为什么他被安排在表演的最后了。没有人想在他之后上台。
I should have known that he'd do well. He's an overachiever. His success came with a rapidity that made all my struggling actor friends heartsick. He spent two snowy months in residency at the MacDowell Writers' Colony. In his first year as a performer, the national cultural correspondent for the New York Times did a big piece on him, calling his stories "morally complex and starkly funny." Producers and screenwriters want to meet with my father. I'll repeat that. Producers and screenwriters want to meet with my father.
我早就该知道他会做得很好。他是那种追求卓越的人。他的成功速度让所有我那些苦苦挣扎的演员朋友们心碎。他在麦克道尔作家驻地度过了两个多雪的月份。在他成为表演者的第一年，《纽约时报》的全国文化记者就为他写了一篇大篇幅的文章，称他的故事“道德复杂且极度幽默”。制片人和编剧想见我父亲。我再说一遍。制片人和编剧想见我父亲。
200 people applied to perform at the prestigious Louisville Arts Festival this year. My father was one of the four people chosen. For eight nights, he performed his one-man show. My father, Fred Rochlin, the artist formerly known as Dad.
今年有200人申请在久负盛名的路易斯维尔艺术节上表演。我父亲是入选的四人之一。在八个夜晚，他表演了他的单人剧。我的父亲，弗雷德·罗克林，原名“爸爸”的艺术家。
Marushka started off in the wrong direction.
玛鲁什卡开始走错方向了。
OK. Almost. Rather than come downstage, I want you to just move to your right.
好吧。差不多了。与其走下舞台，我希望你直接向右移动。
OK. Marushka started off in the wrong direction.
好的。玛鲁什卡开始走错方向了。
Here's another new experience my dad is having in his 70s. He's doing press with his kid. Though he's having all this success, he's not used to being subjected to the opinions of others. Not that long ago, I went to the small theater where my father rehearses. I snuck into the back of the room and watched him roaming around the stage, his words echoing off the walls. At first, he didn't notice I was there. Then he looked up and saw me. And then he looked away. He looked self-conscious. He didn't look like anyone I knew. "This is awkward," he said. I can't remember him ever saying that to me before.
这是我爸爸七十多岁时经历的另一件新鲜事。他正在和他的孩子一起接受媒体采访。尽管他取得了所有这些成功，但他不习惯接受他人的评价。不久前，我去我父亲排练的小剧场。我溜进房间后面，看着他在舞台上踱步，他的话语在墙壁间回响。起初，他没注意到我。然后他抬头看见了我。然后他移开了目光。他看起来很不自然。他看起来不像我认识的任何人。“这很尴尬，”他说。我不记得他以前对我这样说过。
So in other words, the issue of which direction to walk in is raised, dealt with, and resolved all in one spot. And then you move through the next section, which is a whole different thing.
换句话说，关于走哪个方向的问题被提出来、处理了，并在同一个地方解决了。然后你进入下一部分，那完全是另一回事。
My father has a director. Her name is Laurie Lathem. She's a member of the community that he's become a part of that doesn't include his family or his old life. When he first started taking Laurie's classes, he was 30 or 40 years older than everyone else. He didn't seem to mind. This might have been a part of the draw. It made him exotic. I don't know what intrigued him about the out-of-town seminar populated only by militant lesbians. And when I ask him about it now, he pretends not to remember.
我父亲有一位导演。她叫劳里·莱瑟姆。她是那个他新加入的社区成员，那个社区不包括他的家人或他以前的生活。当他刚开始上劳里的课时，他比其他人都大30或40岁。他似乎并不介意。这可能是吸引力的一部分。这让他显得很特别。我不知道那个只由激进女同性恋者组成的外地研讨会有什么吸引他的。现在当我问他时，他假装不记得了。
OK, you're still not telling me about-- I know that you were in a group.
好吧，你还是没跟我说——我知道你参加过一个小组。
I don't know. I really don't know, Margy. I want to be accurate. I don't think so. It may have been some of my folklore, one of my hyperboles.
我不知道。我真的不知道，玛吉。我想准确一点。我不这么认为。那可能是我的民间传说，我的夸张手法之一。
Well, you called me up-- I don't mean to get too insistent here, but you called me up and asked me if I had ever heard of a performer named Muff Diva.
好吧，你给我打电话——我不想表现得太执着，但你确实打电话问我有没有听说过一位叫“莫夫女神”的表演者。
Muff Diva. Well, I was not in her class. I wasn't. I would remember that.
莫夫女神。好吧，我没上过她的课。我没有。我会记得的。
When he first started talking about it, he would tell me funny stories about young women with tattoos, pierced tongues, and shaved heads, who would only do rants about oppression, about how men kept them down, and how when they said the word "men," the entire room would stare at him. Later, he told me it bugged him at first. "I didn't do anything," he said. Then it went on for so long, and they kept staring at him so accusingly, that he couldn't help but be amused.
当他刚开始谈论它时，他会告诉我关于年轻女性的有趣故事，她们有纹身、穿舌钉、剃光头，只会抱怨压迫，抱怨男人如何压制她们，以及当她们说“男人”这个词时，整个房间的人都会盯着他看。后来，他告诉我起初这让他很困扰。“我什么都没做，”他说。然后这种情况持续了太久，她们不停地以指责的目光盯着他，以至于他不禁感到好笑。
But then a couple of days later, he called to tell me that he was feeling ashamed that he'd made light of these women. Their angry diatribes had given way to unhappy memories about leaving home too quickly and parents that were critical of them and of trying to make do on small paychecks from their crummy, menial jobs. These women had stirred protective feelings inside of him. "Their lives are so hard," he told me. "I think they think of me as a father."
但几天后，他打电话告诉我，他因为曾经轻视这些女性而感到羞愧。她们愤怒的抨击演变成了关于过早离家、父母对她们的批评以及试图靠廉价工作的微薄薪水维持生活的不幸回忆。这些女性激发了他内心的保护欲。“她们的生活太艰难了，”他告诉我，“我想她们把我当作了父亲。”
The day after the rehearsal, he does a warm-up show for Louisville. My father's very nervous. Meanwhile, I'm worried that my taping will throw him off. So we pin a wireless mic on him before the performance. And I go outside, and I sit on the stairs. Before the show starts, this is what is recorded straight onto the tape. I don't actually hear it until later.
排练后的第二天，他为路易斯维尔做了一场预演。我父亲非常紧张。同时，我担心我的录音会干扰他。所以我们在表演前给他别了一个无线麦克风。我走到外面，坐在楼梯上。在演出开始前，这些被直接记录在磁带上。我直到后来才听到。
Hitler drove a goddamn BMW. Hitler drove a goddamn BMW, and we're driving them in America today, and it makes me sick. Oh, you son of a-- Hitler drove a goddamn BMW.
希特勒开着该死的宝马。希特勒开着该死的宝马，而我们今天在美国也在开，这让我恶心。哦，你这个狗娘养的——希特勒开着该死的宝马。
What do we want to learn about our parents? What do we want to see? This is an odd thing to admit, but when I took the tape home, I realized that I was scared to listen to it. I was scared of what I might find out. Until I listened to this tape, I'd never heard what my father sounded like when I'm not there. Here's what I found out. When I'm not around, he sounds just like him.
我们想了解父母什么？我们想看到什么？承认这一点很奇怪，但当我把磁带带回家时，我意识到我害怕听它。我害怕我会发现什么。在听到这盘磁带之前，我从没听过我父亲在我不在这儿时是什么样子的。这就是我发现的。当我不在这儿时，他听起来和他本人一模一样。
OK, Frederico?
好的，弗雷德里科？
Esto.
就是这个（Esto）。
This is it. Showtime.
就是现在。开演时间到了。
You bet.
你打赌。
Have a great time.
祝你玩得开心。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Forget everything I told you. Just go out there and be big.
忘掉我告诉你的所有事情。只管走出去，展现大气。
OK.
好的。
Got that?
记住了吗？
It's my stage.
这是我的舞台。
But it's a smaller stage than what you think because we've got a bunch of people sitting on the floor.
但它比你想象的要小，因为我们有一群人坐在地板上。
That makes it better.
那更好。
OK?
好的？
Sure, that's better.
当然，那更好。
So you're just going to have to roll with it.
所以你只需要随遇而安。
Yeah, you bet.
是啊，那是当然。
Have a great time.
祝你玩得开心。
Thank you.
谢谢。
What you do is so beautiful.
你所做的一切真是太美了。
Laurie, you're moving me to tears.
劳里，你让我热泪盈眶。
Every seat is filled. Grown-ups are sitting on the floor, cross-legged. In fact, there were people in the parking lot arguing over the last few tickets. The space where my father's performing is twice as wide as a bowling lane, and there is a chair and an end table with a bottle of Slivovitz on it.
座无虚席。大人们盘腿坐在地板上。实际上，停车场里还有人为了最后几张票争论不休。我父亲表演的地方大约有保龄球道两倍宽，放着一把椅子和一张桌子，上面有一瓶斯利沃维茨（李子白兰地）。
It isn't until the show started that I realized how big of a risk my father's taking. This time, he isn't part of a group. There isn't going to be a girl in a fairy godmother dress babbling about who knows what coming out first so that by comparison, my father seems like the wisest man on the planet. It's just him, slowly working his way towards the front of the audience. And suddenly, I notice I have a terrible knot in my stomach. I sit there on the stairs in the back of the theater.
直到演出开始，我才意识到我父亲冒了多大的险。这一次，他不再是群体的一部分。不会有穿着仙女教母裙的女孩先出来胡言乱语，从而显得我父亲像是这个星球上最睿智的人。只有他自己，缓慢地向观众前方移动。突然，我感觉到胃里一阵难受。我坐在剧场后面的楼梯上。
He gets his first laugh, and then another. And now, I feel so relaxed, I can't even pay attention to what he's saying. All I want to do is stare at the faces in the crowd. Everybody seems to be really enjoying themselves, especially whenever my father mentions anything that has to do with sex.
他收获了第一次笑声，然后是第二次。现在，我感到非常放松，甚至无法注意他在说什么。我只想盯着人群中的脸。每个人似乎都很享受，尤其是当我父亲提到任何与性有关的事情时。
Must've been about noon when Marushka woke me up. And she said, "Fred, you think I no beautiful?" And I said, "What the hell you talking about?" And I looked at her. I could see she was crying. And she said, "Me, Fred, me. I a virgin. I don't want to die virgin. Fred, why don't you put your hand on my shishky? Fred, why don't you put your hooey in my piska? Fred, why don't we make fig-fig?"
中午的时候玛鲁什卡把我叫醒了。她说：“弗雷德，你觉得我不漂亮吗？”我说：“你到底在说什么？”我看着她。我看到她在哭。她说：“我，弗雷德，我。我是处女。我不想死的时候还是处女。弗雷德，你为什么不把手放在我的宝贝上？弗雷德，你为什么不把你的小鸡鸡放进我的小妹妹里？弗雷德，我们为什么不来做爱（fig-fig）？”
You'd think that this would be the part that would disturb me. But it doesn't. What I find jarring is whenever he talks about killing people. There's one particular moment when he talks about shooting three German soldiers. He's been ejected from his plane, is wandering behind enemy lines, meets this woman, Marushka, who is helping him make his way to Italy. They come to a little village full of American sympathizers.
你可能会认为这部分会困扰我。但没有。让我感到刺耳的是他谈到杀人的时候。有一个特定的时刻，他谈到射杀三名德国士兵。他被弹出飞机，在敌后游荡，遇到了这个帮助他前往意大利的女人玛鲁什卡。他们来到一个小村庄，那里到处是美国的支持者。
And the head man came over. He made a speech, and I kept hearing the word "Amerikansky." And then we all started walking off toward the outskirts of this village. There was a little hut there. And Marushka said, "Fred, I know you, Fred. Fred, you're not a hard man. But Fred, if they give you a gun, you must do it, Fred. Even if it's against your nature, you must. Or they will kill you and me." Well, I didn't like the way that sounded. That gave me the creeps.
首领走了过来。他发表了演讲，我一直听到“美国人（Amerikansky）”这个词。然后我们开始走向村庄的外围。那里有个小屋。玛鲁什卡说：“弗雷德，我了解你，弗雷德。弗雷德，你不是个硬心肠的人。但弗雷德，如果他们给你一把枪，你必须去做，弗雷德。即使这违背你的本性，你也必须去做。否则他们会杀了你和我。”好吧，我不喜欢那声音。这让我毛骨悚然。
And we got to this little hut. And the head man spoke some more. And then he yanked on this chain, and from under the hut crawled these three young German boys. They were guys about my age, about 18 or 19 years old. And they had these German gray uniforms on. And they were barefoot and had SS insignia on the collar. And they had a chain around their neck and around their wrists and around their ankles. They'd been terribly beaten up, covered with [BLEEP] from top to bottom. They looked like miserable dogs.
我们到了那个小屋。首领又说了些话。然后他拉了一下链子，从小屋底下爬出了三个年轻的德国男孩。他们大约和我一样大，18或19岁。他们穿着灰色的德国军服。他们赤着脚，领章上有党卫军标志。他们的脖子、手腕和脚踝上都拴着铁链。他们被毒打得很惨，全身沾满排泄物。他们看起来像悲惨的狗。
And then the head man smiled. And I heard the word "Amerikansky." And he handed me the burp gun. And Marushka said, "Fred, you must do it, Fred. You must do it." And the villagers start going, "Chata, chata, chata, chata, chata!" Jesus Christ, I didn't want to shoot anybody. And Marushka was hissing, "Fred, do it, do it." And I pulled the trigger. And the gun went burp! And I just sawed those three boys in half. And the villagers just went wild with excitement. And we started walking back toward the village.
然后那个首领笑了。我听到了“美国人”这个词。他把轻机枪递给我。玛鲁什卡嘶嘶地说：“弗雷德，你必须做，弗雷德。你必须做。”村民们开始喊：“杀他，杀他，杀他！”天哪，我不想射杀任何人。玛鲁什卡尖叫着：“弗雷德，做吧，做吧。”我扣动了扳机。枪响了。我直接把那三个男孩锯成了两半。村民们兴奋得疯狂。我们开始走回村庄。
I've always assumed that this story isn't true. I don't think of my father as this kind of man. In fact, when he showed me an early draft, I told him to take it out. And at first, he did. And then he put it back in. An actor friend of his named Patrick Flanagan told me that one night after class, my father told him that the story about shooting the three German soldiers is true but that he didn't want me or my sisters or my mother to know because he thought it would upset us too much. I asked my dad, "What am I supposed to think?"
我一直认为这个故事不是真的。我不认为我父亲是那种人。事实上，当他给我看初稿时，我让他删掉。起初，他确实删了。后来他又加了回去。他的一个演员朋友帕特里克·弗拉纳根告诉我，一天课后，我父亲告诉他，关于射杀三名德国士兵的故事是真的，但他不想让我、我的姐妹或母亲知道，因为他认为这会让我们太难过。我问我爸爸：“我该怎么想？”
And I was talking to Patrick Flanagan backstage. And he said to me, "You know the whole story. You know what's true and what isn't. And your dad told me that that part of the story is true, that you actually did do those killings.
我在后台和帕特里克·弗拉纳根聊天。他说：“你知道整个故事。你知道什么是真，什么是假。你爸爸告诉我，故事的那部分是真的，你确实杀了人。”
Well, the interesting thing is the idea that somebody would want to know, and particularly an actor, would want to know whether it's true or not true. I don't even think that's an issue. Again, it's a story, it's a metaphor. I don't know, is there a difference in fact and fiction in your mind? Is there?
好吧，有趣的是，有人会想知道，尤其是作为一个演员，会想知道它是真是假。我甚至认为这不是个问题。再说一次，这是一个故事，是一个隐喻。我不知道，在你的脑海里，事实和虚构有区别吗？有吗？
Big.
很大。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. So who are you telling the true story to, me or Patrick?
是的。那你到底是在给谁讲真实故事，给我，还是给帕特里克？
Well, that's up to you to decide.
嗯，那由你自己决定。
Dad, come on.
爸爸，得了吧。
No, I haven't thought this through. You've asked a very good question because other people ask it, too. And I've got to prepare an answer.
不，我没仔细想过。你问了一个很好的问题，因为其他人也问过。我必须准备一个答案。
That's true, but you didn't answer my question. I'm really interested in why-- if, in fact, you told Patrick Flanagan the truth, and me not, why would you do that?
那是真的，但你没回答我的问题。我真的很感兴趣为什么——如果事实上你告诉了帕特里克·弗拉纳根真相，却没告诉我，你为什么要这样做？
I haven't got the vaguest idea what I told Patrick Flanagan.
我一点儿也不记得我对帕特里克·弗拉纳根说了什么。
Oh, OK. But the true story is that the gun was handed to a 13-year-old boy, who killed-- that you did not do those killings.
哦，好吧。但真实的情况是枪递给了一个13岁的男孩，他杀了人——你并没有杀那些人。
That's right. That's a true story. To the best of my knowledge, yeah.
那是对的。那是个真实的故事。据我所知，是的。
To the best of his knowledge? At this point, I have no idea how to assimilate this information. Even seeing my dad squirm under my questions is a side of him I've never seen before. We argued about it so much that I started to get worried. What if he's coming clean about something that he did so many years ago? I asked one of my older sisters if the same thing concerned her. And she told me that she assumes that all the upsetting parts of the story are made up.
据他所知？此时此刻，我不知道该如何理解这些信息。即使看到我父亲在我的问题下不安，也是我从未见过他的一面。我们为此争论得太多，我开始感到担心。如果他坦白了多年前所做的事情怎么办？我问我的一个姐姐，她是否也担心同样的事情。她说她认为故事中所有令人不安的部分都是编造的。
I don't know which version to believe. My father may have shot those soldiers or he may not have. But one thing is for certain. When he goes to these classes, he can be whomever he wants. And God bless him for that. How wonderful for him that he got the chance.
我不知道该相信哪个版本。我父亲可能杀了那些士兵，也可能没有。但有一点是肯定的。当他去上这些课时，他可以成为任何他想成为的人。上帝保佑他。他能有这个机会是多么美好。
Goodbye, fellas. Thanks for coming. Adios. Thank you.
再见，伙计们。感谢你们的到来。再见。谢谢。
After the show, I sit backstage with my father. People start streaming in. Pretty soon, it's like a cocktail party. And Bob, the engineer who's with me, is looking at these two young women who have burst into the room and are hugging and kissing my father. Bob puts his hand over the microphone and says to me, "Your father knows a lot of babes."
演出结束后，我和父亲坐在后台。人们开始涌入。很快，就像一场鸡尾酒会。跟我在一起的工程师鲍勃，看着那两个闯进房间并拥抱亲吻我父亲的年轻女子。鲍勃捂住麦克风对我说：“你爸爸认识不少辣妹。”
The fact that they're babes is a bonus. I think my dad would be just as excited with any kind of fan. What's really wonderful is to see that my father is getting a kind of attention that most people don't get at his age-- frankly, that most people don't get at all.
她们是辣妹只是个额外收获。我想我爸爸对任何粉丝都会同样兴奋。真正美妙的是看到我父亲得到了大多数人到他这个年纪得不到的关注——坦率地说，大多数人根本得不到这种关注。
It's just a huge adventure. God, what fun. Afterwards, last night, it was just fun.
这简直是一次伟大的冒险。天哪，太有趣了。演出后，昨晚，太好玩了。
You mean hanging out and having all those people come and talk--
你是说闲逛和让所有那些人来谈论——
Yeah, then going over and having a few drinks, doing the whole post-mortem. Like, these kids sent me these cards. And I find it very moving.
是啊，然后过去喝了几杯，做了整个复盘。比如，这些孩子给我寄了这些卡片。我觉得非常感人。
Will you read me a card?
你能读给我一张卡片吗？
Well, here, you can read it.
好吧，在这儿，你可以读它。
Can you read it for me?
你能替我读吗？
OK, it says, "Fred, you are such an inspiration to me. Good luck in Louisville." Well, that's very nice. And "Fred, once again, you break my heart and put it back together again." Well, you know, not too many people say that to me very often. "You are a source of great inspiration to me and others. The house ain't full for nothing, Fred. I'm proud to be your friend and collaborator." Well, that's a lot of fun. You just need to be moved there.
好吧，上面写着：“弗雷德，你是我如此大的鼓舞。祝你在路易斯维尔好运。”嗯，那很不错。还有“弗雷德，再一次，你伤透了我的心，又把它缝合起来。”嗯，你知道，不是很多人经常对我这么说。“你是我和其他人极大的灵感来源。满座不是没理由的，弗雷德。我很自豪能成为你的朋友和合作者。”嗯，那很有趣。你只需要在那里被感动。
I didn't know that's what the card said. That's so sweet.
我不知道卡片上写的是这个。太贴心了。
It is. And Margy, to have this happen to me at my stage of life-- Being realistic, I assume when have 10 years left, it's sort of a nice way to spend the last 10 years.
是啊。玛吉，在我这个人生阶段发生这样的事——现实一点说，我假设还能有10年活，这是度过最后10年的一种不错的方式。
When I was growing up, my father kept his leather flight jacket hanging in his closet. I used to go and stare at it. It's really strange to see it on stage when he tells these stories. Painted on the back of it are 50 yellow outlined pictographs shaped like bombs with fins with the nose side down. Two of these are filled with hash marks. These represent the times he was shot down, once near Italy and another time over Yugoslavia.
我成长过程中，我父亲一直把他的皮质飞行夹克挂在壁橱里。我过去常盯着它看。当他在台上讲述这些故事时，穿上它真是太奇怪了。夹克背面画着50个黄色的象形图，形状像带着尾翼的炸弹，尖头朝下。其中有两个涂满了黑线。这些代表他被击落的次数，一次是在意大利附近，另一次是在南斯拉夫上空。
Here's what happened the second time. One engine was shot out, and the other engine quit. So he bailed out over the Adriatic Sea. Everyone but he and the pilot drowned. My father told me that he tread water. And though he's Jewish, he only knew one prayer, the Shema. And he kept reciting it over and over again. And after six hours, he was rescued by a British navy frigate. He was only 20 years old, and he had three more bombing missions to complete before they sent him home.
第二次发生的事情是这样的。一台发动机被击中熄火，另一台也停了。所以他在亚得里亚海上方跳伞。除了他和飞行员外，所有人都淹死了。我父亲告诉我他在水中踩水。虽然他是犹太人，但他只知道一种祈祷文，即《示玛》。他不停地念诵它，一遍又一遍。六小时后，他被一艘英国海军护卫舰营救。他当时才20岁，在他们送他回家之前，他还要完成三次轰炸任务。
I know these details because I've heard the story so many times. But there's something different about hearing him tell stories onstage to strangers. Like the story about how his squadron was supposed to bomb a railroad junction in the town Hajduboszormeny.
我知道这些细节，因为我听过这故事很多次了。但在舞台上向陌生人讲述这些故事感觉完全不同。就像那个关于他的中队本应轰炸匈牙利哈伊杜伯瑟尔梅尼镇一个铁路枢纽的故事。
Now, Hajduboszormeny was obviously not a military target. It was just a little old Hungarian farming town. British intelligence had just made a mistake. But the colonel said, "When in doubt, you always follow orders. You can't go wrong that way." And we were at 22,000 feet. And he brought us down to 8,000 feet. And at 8,000 feet with a Norden bombsight, you can't miss. And we were the first squadron that went in there. And Harry got on the bomb site. And he dropped those bombs. And we just blew the hell out of everything. There was nothing left. Blew up every building, every street, every light post, everything.
现在，哈伊杜伯瑟尔梅尼显然不是军事目标。那只是一个匈牙利的小农镇。英国情报部门搞错了。但上校说：“有疑问时，你总是执行命令。那样做不会错。”我们当时在22000英尺。他把我们带到8000英尺。在8000英尺处用诺登投弹瞄准器，你不可能打偏。我们是第一批进去的中队。哈里在瞄准器上操作。他投下了那些炸弹。我们把一切都炸成了碎片。什么都没剩下。炸毁了每一座建筑、每一条街道、每一盏路灯，一切。
And the next squadron came in. And they dropped their bombs on top of where we had dropped. And then, the next squadron came in. And they dropped their bombs on top of where we had dropped. Then the govern squadron came in. And they dropped their bombs on top of where we had dropped.
然后下一个中队进来了。他们把炸弹投在我们投的地方上面。然后，下一个中队进来了。他们把炸弹投在我们投的地方上面。然后政府的中队进来了。他们把炸弹投在我们投的地方上面。
Look, every plane carries 10,000 pounds of bombs. 10,000 times 28, that's like a quarter million pounds of TNT. Divide that by, say, 2,500 people. That's like 100 pounds of TNT for every man, child, and woman in that village. Hajduboszormeny was no more. It was gone. It was wiped off the face of this earth. It was just a pile of Hungarian dust, a hole in the ground.
听着，每架飞机载有10000磅炸弹。10000乘以28，那就是约25万磅TNT。除以，比如说2500人。那相当于那个镇上每个男人、孩子和女人身上都有100磅TNT。哈伊杜伯瑟尔梅尼不存在了。它没了。它从地球表面被抹去了。它只是一堆匈牙利的尘土，地上的一个洞。
When I hear my father telling these stories onstage, I always think the same thing. After filling up so much space in my imagination, how come I never thought about what it was like to carry those terrible memories around inside of you?
当我听到父亲在台上讲这些故事时，我总是想同样的事情。在我的想象中占据了这么多空间后，为什么我从没想过把这些可怕的记忆带在内心深处是什么感觉？
We landed. I got debriefed. I went back to the officers' club, and I was having a brandy. And Captain Bill Connor, the flight surgeon, came in all smiles. And said, "Hey, Rockets! I just came back from the Carafas'. And the baby's doing great, and the mother's doing fine. And the Carafas are happy as hell. They even asked about you. They wanted to know where was Padrito Frederico. They made you and me godfathers.
我们着陆了。我参加了简报。我回到军官俱乐部，喝着白兰地。飞行军医比尔·康纳上尉满面笑容地走进来，说：“嘿，罗克特！我刚从卡拉法家回来。孩子很好，母亲也没事。卡拉法一家高兴极了。他们甚至问起你。他们想知道弗雷德里科教父在哪儿。他们让我和你当教父。”
Then he looked at me. He said, "What are you so down in the dumps about?" And I said, "Well, Connor, I'm feeling kind of weird. You know how last night you went out and delivered that baby and I kind of helped? And I was proud of that, Connor. And this morning, we went out. And Connor, I guess we killed 2,500, 3,000 people. And I helped. Connor, what the hell's going on? Isn't this some kind of insanity?"
然后他看着我。他说：“你为什么这么沮丧？”我说：“好吧，康纳，我感觉有点怪。你知道昨天晚上你出去接生那个孩子，我帮了忙？我很为此自豪，康纳。而今天早上，我们出去了。康纳，我想我们杀死了2500、3000人。而我也帮了忙。康纳，到底是怎么回事？这难道不是某种疯狂吗？”
And Connor looked at me. "Rockets, you want to go nuts, be put in the booby hatch, be Section 8 out of the army?" "No." "Then you listen to me. And you do what I tell you to do because I'm right. First, you follow orders. You do what you've been trained to do. Then when you're done, just forget it. Forget it. Just forget it. And that drink you're drinking, Rockets, you finish that drink. And when you're done, have another and another. You do that and you'll be all right."
康纳看着我。“罗克特，你想疯掉吗？被关进疯人院，被军队第8条开除吗？”“不。”“那你听我说。你做我告诉你要做的事，因为我是对的。首先，你服从命令。做你受过训练要做的事。然后当你做完时，忘掉它。忘掉它。就忘掉它。而你喝的那杯酒，罗克特，喝完它。当你喝完时，再来一杯，再来一杯。你这样做，你就没事了。”
Well, Connor was right. I did what he said. I did my best to forget. And I pretended, and I denied, and I sure did my share of drinking.
好吧，康纳是对的。我照他说的做了。我尽力去忘记。我假装，我否认，我确实喝了不少酒。
I grew up watching my father drink and laugh. I've seen him stand at the head of a dinner table filled with relatives and friends and raise a glass of wine, and watched tears slide down his face as he cries his way through a toast. I've seen him drink hundreds of times. At celebrations, at sad occasions, late at night in the kitchen when it was just him and me talking. And I have never thought that when he drinks it's because he's trying to forget something. I never thought about it until I saw him tell other people.
我看着父亲喝酒和笑长大。我见过他站在摆满亲戚朋友的餐桌主位上举起酒杯，看着眼泪滑过他的脸颊，他在敬酒中哭泣。我见过他喝醉过几百次。在庆祝活动、悲伤场合，深夜在厨房里只有我和他谈话时。但我从未想过他喝酒是因为他在试图忘记什么。直到我看到他告诉其他人之前，我从没想过。
Margy Rochlin in Los Angeles. Well, coming up, California Governor Pete Wilson in Lycra tights and a superhero mask on a wrestling mat. Well, somebody like Governor Wilson, anyway. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
玛吉·罗克林在洛杉矶。好吧，接下来，加州州长皮特·威尔逊穿着莱卡紧身裤，戴着超级英雄面具在摔跤垫上。好吧，至少像州长威尔逊那样的人。一分钟后，来自公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Leave the Mask On, the stories of those situations where somebody tries to tell you just a little bit more than perhaps you wanted to know at the outset.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目，我们都会选定一个主题，为你带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“保持戴着面具”，讲述那些人们试图告诉你一些比你一开始想知道的还要多一点的信息。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Mama, Can You Hear Me? Well, Dan Savage writes a syndicated sex advice column called "Savage Love." If you've seen it, you know that it's not only more entertaining than most columns of its type. It is very, very explicit. More explicit than-- I can't think of another column as explicit. So explicit, actually, that I actually have three of Dan's last three columns here. And there is not a single question or answer from these three columns that I can quote to you over the radio. I can't even give a kind of gloss, a summary of these questions that I can actually get onto public radio today.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“妈妈，你能听到我吗？”丹·萨维奇写了一个名为“萨维奇的爱”的性建议专栏。如果你看过，你就知道它不仅比大多数同类专栏更有趣。它非常非常露骨。露骨到——我想不出还有哪个专栏如此露骨。实际上，非常露骨，我这儿有丹最近的三篇专栏。从这三篇专栏里，我找不出一个可以在广播里给你引用的问题或答案。我甚至无法对这些问题做一个总结，可以在今天的公共广播里播出。
In real life, Dan will talk with sex about anybody. Anybody except for one group of people with whom he prefers to leave the mask on. A quick warning before we begin this story. Although there's no nasty language or graphic sexual moments in the story, Dan does name a few sex acts. Simply says their names and nothing more.
在现实生活中，丹会和任何人讨论性。除了一个人群，他和他们在一起时宁愿戴着面具。在我们开始这个故事之前先做个简短的警告。虽然故事中没有下流的语言或色情的时刻，但丹确实提到了几种性行为。只是说了它们的名字而已。
I'm not here to talk about sex. I'm here to make a confession, to share with you the secret shame of a sex advice columnist. I cannot talk about sex with my family. Anyone else, anywhere else, any kind of sex. But with family, I become, as my little sister Laura will now tell you, a completely different person.
我不是来谈论性的。我是来做个忏悔，与你分享一位性建议专栏作家的秘密羞耻。我不能和我的家人谈论性。其他人、任何地方、任何种类的性行为都可以。但和家人在一起，就像我小妹妹劳拉现在要告诉你的那样，我变成了一个完全不同的人。
You get all, "Ooh, you're my little sister. I don't want to talk to you about sex. Back off. Eww, that's gross." You get all little girlish about it.
你变得，“哦，你是我小妹妹。我不想和你谈性。走开。咦，那太恶心了。”你变得像个小女孩一样。
How can you say that?
你怎么能那样说？
Because you do. You get all, "Ooh." You turn all red. And you get all high-pitched voiced. And you're all like, "Ooh."
因为你就是那样。你变得，“哦。”你脸变得通红。你的声音变得尖锐。你就像，“哦。”
My parents brought up four kids. Three boys, one girl. Laura is the youngest. When I came out to my family, Laura was thrilled. She finally had a sister. Now there was someone in the family she could dish about boys with. She was having sex with boys. I was having sex with boys. It made perfect sense to her that the two of us should sit up nights, eating brownies and comparing notes.
我父母养育了四个孩子。三个男孩，一个女孩。劳拉是最小的。当我向家人出柜时，劳拉非常激动。她终于有了个姐妹。现在家里有人可以和她八卦男生了。她和男生做爱。我也和男生做爱。对她来说，我们两个晚上坐着吃布朗尼交流经验简直再完美不过了。
I remember one of those early conversations. My sister cornered me on the front porch. She wanted some oral sex tips. When I realized why she had cornered me on the porch that night, I wanted to go right back in the house. But considering how well she'd handled the recent news about my sexuality, it didn't seem fair that I should run in and slam the door on her. So though I was dying inside, I shared with Laura the little I knew at that point about oral sex and then got the hell back in the house.
我还记得那次早期对话。我妹妹在门廊上堵住了我。她想寻求一些口交建议。当我意识到那天晚上她为什么在门廊堵住我时，我想直接跑回屋里。但考虑到她对我性取向新闻处理得那么好，我不跑回屋里关上门似乎不太公平。所以尽管我内心快崩溃了，我还是和劳拉分享了我当时所知的一点关于口交的知识，然后赶紧滚回了屋里。
So of the six of us in the immediate family, if you were to rank everyone for comfort of talking about sex issues, where would I be? Would I be--
在我们直系亲属的六个人里，如果要按谈论性问题的舒适度排名，我会排在哪里？我会是——
You'd be at the bottom.
你会排在最后。
At the bottom? I would?
最后？我会吗？
You'd be at the bottom.
你会排在最后。
But in the extended family, how would you rank me?
但在大家庭里，你会怎么排我？
You mean like Peggy and all those guys?
你是说像佩吉和那些人？
Yeah, like Peggy, Nestor, Amy, Tracy. The whole sort of crowd, the extended family. The aunts, the uncles, the cousins.
是的，比如佩吉、内斯特、艾米、特雷西。整个大家庭。阿姨、叔叔、表亲。
You'd still be close to the bottom.
你仍然接近最后。
I would still be close to the bottom.
我仍然接近最后吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
I'm not sure where my discomfort came from. My parents were open with us about sex. They would use any opportunity that came along to initiate an educational conversation with us kids about sex. But I'm not convinced their openness was entirely sincere. In the late '70s, moms and dads were under a lot of pressure to be hip. And talking openly with your teens about sex was very hip.
我不确定我的不适感从何而来。我父母对性很开放。他们会抓住任何机会对我们孩子进行性教育。但我并不相信他们的开放是完全真诚的。70年代末，妈妈和爸爸们承受着很大的压力要显得时髦。而与青少年公开谈论性是非常时髦的。
It's funny how different people often remember shared experiences in vastly different ways. I recall the times my mother and father talked to us about sex basically like this. They didn't want to talk to us about it. They didn't like talking to us about it. They weren't any good at talking about it. But by god, they were going to be hip parents if it killed them. But maybe I remember those conversations that way because, in fact, I was the one in agony. My mother remembers those conversations differently.
不同的人对共同经历的记忆方式往往截然不同，这很有趣。我记得父母跟我们谈论性的那些时刻，基本是这样的：他们不想和我们谈，他们不喜欢和我们谈，他们也不擅长谈论。但天哪，如果那样能让他们成为时髦的父母，他们甚至不惜死。但也可能因为我当时确实备受煎熬，所以才那样记忆。而我母亲对这些对话的记忆不同。
We wanted to talk to you about sex. Or at least I did. I can't speak for your father. We thought that we were going to be these great, wonderful, open parents and give you all sorts of information.
我们想和你谈论性。或者至少我想。我不能代表你父亲。我们以为我们要成为那种伟大、美妙、开放的父母，给你们提供各种信息。
And you sensed that we were uncomfortable having the conversation?
你感觉到我们对谈论这个感到不舒服吗？
Well, sometimes you used to cover your ears and say, "I don't want to talk about that with you."
嗯，有时你习惯捂住耳朵说：“我不想和你谈论那个。”
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I did that?
我那样做了吗？
Yes.
是的。
I remember one run-from-the-room conversation. My brother Eddie came down to dinner wearing a T-shirt with an oral sex innuendo decal ironed onto it. The four of us kids were snickering. And my parents asked us if we really knew what that T-shirt meant. Then my father explained to us, in great detail, all about oral sex. It was 1978. I was 13 years old. And from watching Three's Company and Hollywood Squares , I had managed to work out exactly what oral sex was all on my own. I didn't need my father to explain it to me with a mouthful of shepherd's pie.
我记得一次“从房间里跑出来”的对话。我哥哥埃迪穿着一件T恤下楼吃饭，上面熨着一个含蓄口交内容的图案。我们四个孩子在那儿偷笑。父母问我们是否真的知道那件T恤意味着什么。然后父亲非常详细地给我们解释了关于口交的一切。那是1978年。我当时13岁。通过看《三人行》和《好莱坞方块》，我已经设法完全靠自己搞清楚了口交是什么。我不需要父亲一边吃着牧羊人馅饼一边给我解释。
Then Mom dropped the bomb. There was nothing wrong with oral sex, she said, so long as the man and the woman engaging in it were in love. Why, she and my father engaged in oral sex. That was all I needed to hear to put me off oral sex for about 15 years. And shepherd's pie.
然后妈妈抛出了重磅炸弹。她说口交没什么错，只要参与的男人和女人是相爱的。为什么，她和父亲也进行口交。那是所有我需要听到的，让我对口交倒胃口了大约15年。还有牧羊人馅饼。
Part of my problem with those parent-kid conversations about sex was a too-vivid imagination. When you're talking about sex with someone, it's hard not to form mental pictures of them actually having sex. And no one likes to picture their parents having sex. When I answer letters in my column, it's different. I don't know what these people look like. I can picture whoever I want. So unless gender comes into the question in some material way, I picture Matt Damon and Brad Pitt. Together. In fact, let's all take a moment, shall we, to enjoy that picture.
我对那些父母与孩子关于性的对话感到困扰的部分原因是我那太丰富的想象力。当你和某人谈论性时，很难不去想象他们真正在做爱的画面。没人喜欢想象自己的父母做爱。当我在专栏里回答信件时，这不同。我不知道这些人长什么样。我可以想象任何我想象的人。所以除非性别在问题中以某种实质方式出现，否则我想象的是马特·达蒙和布拉德·皮特。在一起。事实上，让我们都花点时间，享受那个画面吧，好吗？
OK, back to the radio show. Since I started writing a sex column, this thing with the family has gotten worse, especially with my mother. During the darkest days of the AIDS crisis, my mother would grill me about my sex life, asking me the most graphic, intense, probing, involved questions. She was absolutely prosecutorial. She wanted to know what sorts of risks I was taking, with whom, how often, under what circumstances, how much I'd had to drink, what this boy's intentions toward me were, where he was raised, what his people did, how much lube we were using, what kind of condoms we used. I've had conversations with my mother about the theory and practice of anal sex that I don't think many people, living or dead, have had with anyone, least of all their mothers.
好的，回到广播节目。自从我开始写性专栏，和家人的这件事就变得更糟了，尤其是和我母亲。在艾滋病危机的至暗时刻，母亲会盘问我的性生活，问我最露骨、最强烈、最深入、最复杂的问题。她简直像个检察官。她想知道我冒了什么风险、和谁、频率多少、什么情况下、喝了多少酒、这个男孩对我的意图如何、他在哪儿长大、他家人做什么、我们用了多少润滑剂、用了什么种类的安全套。我和母亲谈论过关于肛交的理论和实践，我想很多人，无论生者还是死者，都不会和任何人谈论，尤其是他们的母亲。
My mother confides in me, too. We talk about her sex life sometimes. And I've given her advice. But that's as much as I can tell you. Please, please don't ask me for details.
我母亲也信任我。有时我们会谈论她的性生活。我给过她建议。但我只能告诉你这么多。拜托，拜托不要问我细节。
When you and I talk about sex, it seems to me that it's mostly at your instigation. Do you think we discuss sex more than your average mother and son?
当你和我谈论性时，在我看来主要是你发起的。你认为我们讨论性的次数比一般母子多吗？
Probably. I don't really know.
可能吧。我真不知道。
Do you talk to my brothers about sex?
你和我的兄弟们谈论性吗？
Not really. I don't talk to very many people about sex.
并不是。我不和很多人谈论性。
Do you talk to Laura, my sister, about sex?
你和劳拉，我妹妹，谈论性吗？
No.
不。
See, but you do talk to me about it. And why do you think that is? Is it because I work in sex, or is it because I'm gay, or is it because we're exceptionally close?
你看，但你确实和我谈论它。你认为为什么？是因为我从事性行业，还是因为我是同性恋，还是因为我们特别亲密？
I think we've always had different conversations since you were a little person. Our conversations always tended to get more intense or to cover more area.
我想自你很小的时候起，我们就一直有不同的对话。我们的对话往往更强烈或者涵盖更多领域。
The only time my mother gets upset about our sex conversations is when I reproduce them in my column. My mom was very upset when my column started running in a weekly paper in our hometown, where she still lives. That first week it ran there, I mentioned details of what she thought was a private conversation we'd had about sex many years before. So now when we talk about sex, my mother takes me on and off the record, like a highly placed Washington source. "Daniel, we're off the record," she'll say before we get into a conversation that I, in all honesty, would rather not be having. When the conversation turns back to more mundane things, she'll announce, "Alrighty, we're back on the record." My mom's a regular Deep Throat. That's a Watergate reference, Mom.
我母亲唯一对我们的性谈话感到不安的时候，就是当我在专栏里再现它们时。当我开始在老家的一份周报上刊登专栏时，我妈非常生气，她还住在那里。第一周刊登时，我提到了她认为很多年前我们就性进行的一次私下谈话的细节。所以现在当我们谈论性时，我母亲会像一位华盛顿高级线人一样，把我列为“非正式记录”。“丹尼尔，我们现在是私下记录，”在开始一场说实话我宁愿不进行的对话之前她会这么说。当谈话转回更平凡的事情时，她会宣布，“好吧，我们回到公开记录了。”我妈是个彻头彻尾的“深喉”。那是水门事件的参考，妈。
Do you think that when I came out, when I told the family I was gay, I sort of made sex an issue in a way? Made sexuality and sex an issue, my sex and sexuality, in the family? So do you think that sort of invited conversations about sex?
你认为当我出柜，当我告诉家人我是同性恋时，我以某种方式让性成为了一个议题吗？让性取向和性成为一个议题，我的性和性取向？你认为那邀请了关于性的对话吗？
Oh, definitely. I think your openness brings it out in a lot of people. And you're so open about it, people don't stop to think that it's a subject that you don't want to discuss or there are people that you don't want to discuss it with.
哦，绝对。我认为你的开放让很多人的那种欲望显露出来。你对它太开放了，人们不会停下来想这是一个你不想讨论的主题，或者有些你不愿意和他们讨论的人。
Or that I'm only open about it when I'm getting paid. So I'm kind of like a prostitute.
或者我只有在拿钱的时候才对此开放。所以我有点像个妓女。
I don't know if I'd say that.
我不知道我会那样说。
I would hope that you wouldn't.
我希望你不会。
Good. Well, I won't. Your private persona is very different than your public persona in many areas of your life.
好的。好吧，我不会。你在生活中许多领域的私人形象与公共形象非常不同。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Don't ruin me here, Ma. Don't let the cat out of the bag. I've got a sweet gig going. I don't want it ruined by this interview.
妈，别毁了我。别把真相泄露出去。我有一份甜美的工作。我不想让这次采访毁了它。
What's it worth? No. It's not as raw and crude and uncaring as you sometimes come across in print.
值多少钱？不。你并没有你有时在印刷品中表现出来的那么粗鲁、粗糙和冷漠。
Mom, I'm hurt.
妈，我受伤害了。
There, I told on you.
看吧，我告发你了。
Here's the worst thing of all. Since it's common knowledge now that I'm uncomfortable talking about sex with my family, it's become a game, the best way to tease me when I'm home for a visit. At a wedding last month, word spread through my immediate and extended family that I had interviewed my mom and my sister for this radio show about how uncomfortable I am talking with my family about sex. People thought that was pretty funny, considering what I do for a living.
这是最糟糕的事情。既然现在大家都知道我不喜欢和家人谈论性，这成了一个游戏，是我回家探亲时他们取笑我最好的方式。上个月在婚礼上，消息在我的直系和大家庭中传开，说我采访了妈妈和妹妹来做这个关于我和家人谈论性有多不舒服的广播节目。人们认为那相当有趣，考虑到我是干什么为生的。
Sensing blood in the water, they came after me. Everybody had a sex question for me that day. Aunts, uncles, nieces, nephews, great aunts, siblings, the happy couple. My aunt wouldn't let me leave her table until I told her what fisting was. My brother told me all about his last one-nighter. And like some reoccurring nightmare, a female cousin, the same age as my sister was that night on the porch cornered me at the bar and asked for oral sex pointers. By the time my 17-year-old cousin, Chris, insisted on showing me his new nipple rings, I was in hell. When I complained to my mother, she told me to stop whining. Then she asked me a sex question herself. I'd tell you what her question was, but Mom took me off the record.
感觉到了血腥味，他们盯上了我。那天每个人都有关于性的问题要问我。阿姨、叔叔、侄女、侄子、姨婆、兄弟姐妹，幸福的一对。我阿姨不让我离开她的桌子，直到我告诉她什么是“拳交”。我哥哥告诉了我他上一次的一夜情。像是一场反复出现的噩梦，一个和我妹妹当年在门廊时年龄一样的女性表亲在吧台堵住我，寻求口交建议。当我17岁的表弟克里斯坚持要给我看他新的乳头环时，我简直在地狱。当我向母亲抱怨时，她让我别再发牢骚了。然后她自己也问了我一个性问题。我会告诉你她的问题是什么，但妈妈把我列为“非正式记录”了。
Dan Savage in Seattle.
丹·萨维奇在西雅图。
[MUSIC - "WHAT'S BEHIND THE MASK" BY THE CRAMPS]
（音乐 - The Cramps的“面具背后是什么”）
Act Three, The Unmasking. Well, now the story of masks that are not metaphorical, of guys who wear Lycra masks and brightly colored capes and wrestle for a living in Mexican wrestling matches known as lucha libre, which roughly translates to "free fight." RJ Smith tells the story.
第三幕，“摘下面具”。现在是关于面具的故事，那些不是隐喻的面具，那些穿着莱卡面具和色彩鲜艳斗篷的家伙，他们在墨西哥摔跤比赛中以此为生，比赛被称为“墨西哥自由摔跤（lucha libre）”，大致翻译为“自由搏击”。RJ·史密斯讲述了这个故事。
Something about a mask makes a man brazen. That's the thing Atomic Blue taught me. Atomic Blue was the first Mexican wrestler I met. Picture a man in a skull-hugging blue mask, an atom drawn across the forehead, not to mention his Matt Helm black turtleneck, black jeans, tweed jacket, and really fine leather shoes. If Atomic Blue had a code ring, he'd be encrypting. If he had a martini, he'd be imbibing. He's bad. It's Atomic Blue who taught me that Mexican wrestling is not just a sport. Lucha libre is an art form, a tradition, a battle of good versus evil. Lucha libre, Atomic Blue said, is religion.
面具里的某种东西让人变得胆大妄为。这就是原子蓝教会我的。原子蓝是我见过的第一个墨西哥摔跤手。想象一个戴着紧贴头颅的蓝色面具的男人，额头上画着一个原子，更不用说他那马特·赫尔姆风格的黑色高领毛衣、黑色牛仔裤、粗花呢夹克和非常精致的皮鞋。如果原子蓝有解码戒指，他会进行加密。如果他有马丁尼，他会啜饮。他很棒。是原子蓝教会我墨西哥摔跤不仅仅是一项运动。墨西哥自由摔跤是一种艺术形式，一种传统，一场正义对抗邪恶的战斗。原子蓝说，墨西哥自由摔跤是宗教。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
（西班牙语讲话）。
The greatest of all wrestling heroes was El Santo, "The Saint," who not only fought in the ring, but on the screen. From the '40s down to the present, dozens of wrestling stars have played in hundreds of incredibly strange movies, wrapping their limbs around plot devices pried from horror, crime, and science fiction genres. Santo might easily break up a spy ring, pitch woo at a backseat full of chicas, and defeat martians, all in the same picture.
最伟大的摔跤英雄是“圣徒（El Santo）”，他不仅在擂台上战斗，也在银幕上战斗。从40年代到现在，几十位摔跤明星在数百部极其奇特的电影中扮演角色，将四肢缠绕在从恐怖、犯罪和科幻类型中强行剥离出来的剧情装置上。圣徒可以轻松捣毁一个间谍组织，在满是辣妹的后座上调情，并打败火星人，所有这些都在同一部电影里完成。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
（西班牙语讲话）。
Santo did everything without removing his disguise. Even when he directed his pictures, even when he was buried in 1984, Mexico's saint always kept his mask on.
圣徒做一切事情都不摘下伪装。即使当他导演自己的电影时，即使在1984年他被埋葬时，墨西哥的圣徒总是戴着他的面具。
We're in a parking lot behind an Anaheim swap meet. Every weekend, they pull a plastic tarp off a regulation ring, set up metal bleachers. It's $10 for adults, who bring plenty of kids. About 50 fans surround the ring this afternoon. Shooting Star wears a black mask. Orange bolts crease his temples. In lucha libre, there are good guys, known as "tecnicos," and bad guys, "rudos." Guess which one Shooting Star is.
我们在阿纳海姆一个跳蚤市场后面的停车场。每个周末，他们都会从一个标准的擂台上拉下一块塑料防水布，架起金属看台。成年人门票10美元，他们带来很多孩子。大约50名粉丝今天下午围在擂台周围。流星（Shooting Star）戴着黑色面具。橙色的螺栓弄皱了他的太阳穴。在墨西哥自由摔跤中，有被称作“技术流（tecnicos）”的好人，和“粗鲁派（rudos）”的坏人。猜猜流星是哪一种。
What country are you guys in, huh?
你们这些家伙在哪个国家，嗯？
USA! USA!
美国！美国！
Mexico! Mexico! Mexico!
墨西哥！墨西哥！墨西哥！
Every time he yells, "USA," fans scream back, "Mexico!" Shooting Star preens before the hostile crowd. He issues challenges to his opponent, to the fans, and, it seems, maybe even to God. It's getting ugly.
每次他大喊“美国”，粉丝们就尖叫着回应“墨西哥！”流星在敌对的人群面前显得十分傲慢。他向对手、向粉丝，甚至似乎向神发出挑战。情况变得糟糕了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
（西班牙语讲话）。
I didn't quite get that, did you? I don't under-- English, maybe? Is English the country--
我不完全明白那个，你明白吗？我不明白——英语，也许？英语是那个国家——
In Spanish, Shooting Star calls the hecklers "dirty wetbacks," asks if they're citizens of the US. It seems like everything in Mexican culture, people's worries and fears, plays out in the ring. So it's no surprise that there's a wrestler who's the equivalent of a masked Governor Pete Wilson playing the bad guy, taunting the immigrants in the crowd. What happens in Mexican life happens again in the ring.
用西班牙语，流星称起哄者为“肮脏的背水者（墨西哥非法移民蔑称）”，询问他们是否是美国公民。似乎墨西哥文化中的一切，人们的担忧和恐惧，都在擂台上展现。所以有一个摔跤手相当于一个戴着面具的皮特·威尔逊州长，扮演坏人，嘲弄人群中的移民，这并不奇怪。墨西哥生活中发生的事情在擂台上重演。
No one's talking to you, so you just keep your mouth shut.
没人跟你说话，所以你闭上你的嘴。
A couple years ago, when reports of a blood-sucking creature feasting on farm animals first shocked Mexico, a new wrestling star called The Goat Sucker suddenly appeared. Other heroes include wrestling priests and social workers. In today's match, one of the luchadores was named El Cholo, a wrestler dressed as a gang banger in saggy pants and colors, flashing gang signs.
几年前，当关于一种以农场动物为食的吸血生物的报道首次震惊墨西哥时，一个名为“吸山羊怪”的新摔跤明星突然出现了。其他英雄包括摔跤牧师和社会工作者。在今天的比赛中，其中一名自由摔跤手名叫埃尔·乔洛（El Cholo），一个打扮成帮派成员的摔跤手，穿着松垮的裤子和帮派颜色，闪现帮派手势。
The luchadore reaches back to prehistoric mass religious rituals of American Indians and echoes to this moment. Many have pointed out how the suave, pipe-smoking, ski-masked, sub-commander Marcos, leader of the Zapatista rebels in northern Mexico, calculatedly evokes the image of El Santo. It's as if Hulk Hogan somehow carried within his form overtones of Daniel Boone and Martin Luther King.
这位自由摔跤手回溯到美洲印第安人史前大众宗教仪式，并呼应着此时此刻。许多人指出，那在墨西哥北部领导萨帕塔叛军的斯文、抽烟斗、戴滑雪面具、副指挥官马科斯，是如何刻意唤起“圣徒”的形象。就好像绿巨人霍根以某种方式在他的形式中承载了丹尼尔·布恩和马丁·路德·金的弦外之音。
This is the power of the mask. It makes superheroes out of die cutters, mechanics, gardeners. In Anaheim, I even met a wrestler who was a chiropractic student. In the ring, a character named El Genie wears harem pants and performs a move he calls "the magic lamp." During the week, the tall, beefy man with a black pony tail is a car upholsterer.
这就是面具的力量。它把模具切割工、机械师、园丁变成了超级英雄。在阿纳海姆，我甚至遇到了一位是脊椎按摩医学生的摔跤手。在擂台上，一个名为“精灵（El Genie）”的角色穿着灯笼裤，表演他称之为“魔灯”的招式。平日里，这个留着黑色马尾辫的高大、强壮的男人是一个汽车装潢师。
When I first started doing this, it was hard to get back to doing what I did, to be in upholstery. Because I would miss being out there, being the superstar. I'd miss it. But in our culture, in the Mexican culture, you get a lot of respect. For example, every time I go to Mexico and I go out-- let's say I go to a dance or something-- I get special treatment. They give me a table, and they treat me to drinks. And it's kind of funny because that's how people are.
当我刚开始做这个时，很难回到我以前做的事情，去做装潢。因为我会怀念在外面的时光，怀念做超级英雄。我会怀念它。但在我们的文化中，在墨西哥文化中，你会得到很多尊重。例如，每次我去墨西哥，我出门——比如说我去跳舞之类的——我会得到特殊待遇。他们给我一张桌子，请我喝酒。这很有趣，因为人就是那样。
As soon as you put the mask on, you feel like a total different person. If you're a "heel," which is a bad guy, all of a sudden, you feel this urge to hurt, to inflict pain. And if you're a "face," a good guy, you feel like you've got to go and save the world. It's funny, and it happens.
一旦你戴上面具，你就会感觉自己是一个完全不同的人。如果你是一个“坏蛋（heel）”，也就是坏人，突然间，你会感觉到伤害、造成痛苦的冲动。如果你是一个“好人（face）”，你会感觉必须走出去拯救世界。这很有趣，它确实会发生。
When someone takes your mask off in the ring, and they just take it off, it's like a humiliation. You get humiliated when someone takes your mask off. Whoever loses that match has to take off their mask and never wrestle with it again. It happened to me, yeah. I went against one of the top wrestlers in Mexico. And I lost it in the Mexicali against Fishman. His name was Fishman. And he was my idol as I was growing up. But it came to a head. We had a rivalry that came to a head. And we bet our masks, and he got the better part. And that's the biggest humiliation you can receive in the ring, losing your mask.
当有人在擂台上摘下你的面具时，他们就只是把它摘下来，这就像是一种羞辱。当有人摘下你的面具时，你会被羞辱。无论谁输了那场比赛，都必须摘下面具，永远不能再戴着它摔跤。它确实发生在我身上。我对抗了墨西哥顶级摔跤手之一。我在墨西卡利输给了“鱼人（Fishman）”。他的名字叫鱼人。他是我成长过程中的偶像。但它达到了顶点。我们有一场竞争达到了顶点。我们押上了我们的面具，他赢了。那是你在擂台上能受到的最大的羞辱，失去你的面具。
I saw it once, and I'll never forget. It happened last spring. And for weeks after, I had dreams of masked men, wrestlers, hockey goalies, the guys in KISS. It was the last match of the night, Bulldog Rivera versus Shamu Junior. Shamu was a pudgy tecnico. Nobody had to wonder how he got the name Shamu, no wonder about the whale appliques decorating his Aqua Velva blue mask. The fight was even for a while. But then Bulldog climbs the ropes, leaps at Shamu Junior's torso, and knocks him to his knees. Shamu Junior's in a fog. And Bulldog smoothly reaches back for the laces binding his mask.
我见过一次，我永远不会忘记。它发生在去年春天。之后几周，我梦见戴面具的人、摔跤手、冰球守门员、KISS乐队的人。那是当晚最后一场比赛，斗牛犬里维拉（Bulldog Rivera）对阵沙姆小弟（Shamu Junior）。沙姆是一个圆滚滚的“技术流”。没人需要怀疑他是怎么得到沙姆这个名字的，也无需怀疑那些装饰在他阿夸维尔瓦蓝色面具上的鲸鱼贴花。比赛势均力敌了一段时间。但随后斗牛犬爬上绳索，扑向沙姆小弟的躯干，把他撞倒在地。沙姆小弟在迷糊中。斗牛犬顺滑地伸手去够系住他面具的鞋带。
Oh, god. Everything was going through my-- I thought I would never do it again, I would never wrestle again, that people were just going to forget me right away because I had lost. And I wasn't going to get over it. And it felt-- I cried on top of the ring. I cried when I lost my mask. It was something-- god, it's hard to describe. But it was a feeling of-- I felt alone. I felt so alone that day. But that night, one of my sons was there. And he came up to the ring, and he gave me a hug. And it felt good. It felt a lot better. This is his words. He said, "You know, Dad, it's just a mask. You know?"
哦，天哪。一切都在我的脑海中闪过——我以为我永远不会再做了，我永远不会再摔跤了，人们会因为我输了而立刻忘记我。我不会走出来。它感觉——我在擂台上哭了。我输掉面具时哭了。那是某种——天哪，很难描述。但那是一种——我感到孤独。那天我感到非常孤独。但那天晚上，我的一个儿子在那里。他走到擂台边，给了我一个拥抱。那感觉很好。感觉好多了。这是他的原话。他说：“你知道，爸爸，那只是个面具。你懂吗？”
The unmasking. It's the most sacramental moment. And over the next few minutes, Bulldog returns to the act at will, almost tenderly unlacing as Shamu Junior futilely resists. His head cradled in Bulldog's lap, Shamu Junior pleads with the ref. But then, Bulldog sends the ref sprawling with a kick. There is no hope now. Armed security men are restraining a lady in her 40s with a dye job. All around, there's a call for blood.
摘下面具。这是最庄严的时刻。在接下来的几分钟里，斗牛犬随意地完成了动作，几乎温柔地解开，而沙姆小弟徒劳地反抗。沙姆小弟的头被抱着斗牛犬的怀里，恳求裁判。但随后，斗牛犬一脚把裁判踢开。现在没有希望了。武装警卫正在制止一位染了发的40多岁女士。周围到处都是对鲜血的呼唤。
In an act of lyric defiance, Shamu Junior undoes the rest of his own laces and flings his mask at his opponent. He is utterly humiliated. Losing your mask is like losing your ego, manhood, superpowers, and, since fans typically turn on you, your opportunity to make cash off the books. He buries his face in his hands, fighting off Bulldog's probing fingers. Finally, Bulldog pries away Shamu's hands, and we see his face. Degraded without the mask, he's just a guy, a buzz cut of dark hair, short on the sides. It's the day before Easter. Christ may have risen, but Shamu Junior is taking a fall.
在一场抒情的反抗中，沙姆小弟解开了自己剩下的鞋带，并把面具扔向他的对手。他被彻底羞辱了。失去面具就像失去你的自尊、男子气概、超级能力，而且，因为粉丝通常会背叛你，你失去在书本之外赚钱的机会。他双手捂住脸，对抗着斗牛犬试探性的手指。最后，斗牛犬拨开沙姆的手，我们看到了他的脸。没有面具的贬低，他只是个家伙，留着黑发平头，侧面剪得很短。那是复活节前一天。基督可能复活了，但沙姆小弟正在倒下。
RJ Smith is a senior writer for Spin magazine. He had help in the field from Mandalit del Barco.
RJ·史密斯是《Spin》杂志的资深作家。他在现场得到了曼达利特·德尔·巴尔科的帮助。
[MUSIC - "TUBTHUMPING" BY CHUMBAWUMBA]
（音乐 - Chumbawamba的“Tubthumping”）
Well, our program was introduced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Senior editor, Paul Tough. Contributing editors, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consligliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Day, Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus.
嗯，我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人介绍，还有南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德。资深编辑，保罗·托夫。特约编辑，杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自雷切尔·戴、乔治·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our program for free at our website www.thisamericanlife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目或我们任何节目的盒式磁带，请致电芝加哥，312-832-3380。或者你知道你可以在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org免费收听我们大部分的节目。感谢管理该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。本《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资金资助致谢）
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who envisions the future of our program this way--
WBEZ管理层监管由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他这样设想我们节目的未来——
I picture Matt Damon and Brad Pitt. Together.
我想象的是马特·达蒙和布拉德·皮特。在一起。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
公共广播国际（PRI）。